given that you are once again one of the
greatest programmers ever
uh what do you think makes a good
programmer
maybe a good modern programmer
so i just gave a long rant slash lecture
at meta to the tpm organization and my
my biggest point was everything that
we're doing really should flow from user
value you know all the good things that
we're doing it's like we're we're not
technical people it's like
you shouldn't be taking pride just in
the specific thing like code golf is the
sort of thing it's a fun puzzle game but
that really should not be a major
motivator for you it's like we're
solving problems for people or we're
providing entertainment to people we're
doing something of value to people
that's displacing something else in
their life so we want to be providing a
net value over what they could be doing
uh but instead they're choosing to use
our products and that's where i mean it
sounds trite or corny but i
fundamentally do think that's how you
make the world a better place if you
have given more value to people than it
took you and your team to create
then the world's a better place people
have they've gone from something of
lesser value chosen to use your product
and their life feels better for that and
if you've produced that economically
that's
that's a really good thing i you know on
the other hand if you spent ridiculous
amounts of money you've just kind of
shoveled a lot of cash into a wood
chipper there and you should maybe you
know not feel so good about what you're
doing
so
being proud about like a specific
architecture or specific technology or a
specific code sequence that you've done
it's great to get a little smile like a
tiny little dopamine hit for that but
the top level metric should be that
you're building things of value now you
can get in the argument about how you
you know what is user value how do you
actually quantify that and there can be
big arguments about that but it's easy
to be able to say okay this pissed off
user there is not getting value from
what you're doing this user over there
with the big smile on their face i am
the moment of delight when something
happened there's a value that's happened
there i mean if you you have to at least
accept that there is a concept of user
value even if you have trouble exactly
quantifying it you can usually make
relative arguments about it well this
was better than this uh we've improved
things
so
you know being a
you know being a servant to the user is
your job when you're doing when you're a
developer you want to be producing
something that i you know other people
are going to find valuable
and if you are technically inclined then
finding the right levers to be able to
pull to be able to
make a design that's going to produce
the most value for the least amount of
effort and it always has to be i kind of
divide there's a ratio there where you
it's a problem at the big tech companies
you know whether it's you know meta
google apple microsoft amazon companies
that have almost infinite money i i mean
i know
their cfo will complain that it's not
infinite money but from most developer
standpoints it really does feel like it
and it's almost counterintuitive that
if you're working hard as a developer on
something there's always this thought if
only i had more resources more people
more ram more megahertz i
then my product will be better and that
sense that at certain points it's
certainly true that if you are really
hamstrung by this removing an obstacle
will will make a better product make
more value
but if you're not making your core
design decisions in this fiercely
competitive
way where you're saying feature a or
feature b you can't just say let's do
both uh because then you're not making a
value judgment about them you're just
saying well they both seem good i don't
want to necessarily have to pick out
which one is better or how much better
and tell team b that sorry we're not
going to do this because a is more
important
but that i am that notion of always
having to really critically value what
you're doing your time the resources you
expend even the opportunity cost of
doing something else
that's you know super important well let
me ask you about this the big
debates that you're mentioning of how to
measure value
is it possible to measure it kind of um
numerically
uh or can you do the sort of johnny eye
the designer route of imagining
sort of uh somebody using a thing and
imagining a smile on their face
imagining the experience of love and joy
that you have when you use the thing
that's from a design perspective or if
you're building more like a low lower
level thing for like linux you imagine a
developer that might come across this
and use it and become
uh
happy and better off because of it
so where do you land on those things is
it measurable so i imagine like meta
and google
will probably try to measure the thing
they'll try to it's like you try to
optimize engagement or something let's
measure engagement and then i think
there is a kind of
i mean i admire the designer ethic of
like
think of a future that's immeasurable
and you try to make somebody in that
future that's different from today happy
so i do
usually favor if you can get any kind of
a a metric that's good by all means
listen to the data but you can go too
far there where we've had problems where
it's like hey we had a performance
regression because our fancy new
telemetry system is doing a bazillion
file rights uh to kind of archive this
stuff because we needed to collect
information to determine if we were
doing you know if our plans were good so
when information is available you should
never ignore it i mean for the actual
users using the thing
human beings using the thing large
number of human beings and you get to
see sort of at least so there's the zero
to one problem of when you're doing
something really new you do kind of have
to make a guess but one of the points
that i've been making at meta is
we have more than enough users now that
anything somebody wants to try in vr we
have users that will be interested in
that you do not get to make a completely
green field blue sky pitch and say i'm
going to do this because i think it
might be interesting i challenge
everyone there are going to be people
whether it's you know working in vr on
your i'm
like on your desktop replacement or
communicating with people in different
ways or playing the games
there are going to be
probably millions of people or at least
in if you pick some tiny niche that
we're not in right now there's still
going to be thousands of people out
there that have the headsets that would
be your target market and i tell people
pay attention to them don't invent
fictional users don't you know make an
alice bob charlie uh that fits whatever
matrix of uh of tendencies that you want
to break the market down to because it's
a mistake to think about imaginary users
when you've got real users that you
could be working with
but you know on the other hand there is
there is value to having a kind of
wholeness of vision for a product and
um companies like meta have
you know they understand the trade-offs
where you can have a company like spacex
or you know apple in the the steve jobs
era where you have a very powerful
leading personality that i you know they
can micromanage at a very low level and
can say it's like no that handle needs
to be different or that that icon needs
to change the tint there and they
clearly get a lot of value out of it
they also burn through a lot of
employees that have horror stories to
tell about working there afterwards
my position is that
you're at your best when you've got a
leader that is at their limit of what
they can kind of comprehend of
everything below them uh and they can
have an informed opinion about
everything that's going on and you take
somebody it's you've got to believe that
somebody that has 30 40 years of
experience you would hope that they've
got wisdom that the the just out of boot
camp person uh contributing doesn't have
and that if they're like well that's
wrong there you probably shouldn't do it
that way or or even just don't do it
that way do it another way
so there's value there but it can't go
beyond a certain level i am i mean i
have steve jobs stories of him saying
things that are just wrong right in
front of me about technical things
because he was not operating at that
level
i
but when it does work and you do get
that kind of passionate leader that's
thinking about the entire product and
just really deeply cares about not
letting anything slip through the cracks
i i think that's got a lot of value but
the other side of that is the people
saying that well we want to have these
independent teams that are bubbling up
the ideas because like it's it's almost
it's anti-capitalist or anti-free market
to say it's like i want my grand you
know my great leader to go ahead and
dictate all these points there where
clearly free markets bring up things
that you know you don't expect like in
vr we we saw a bunch of things like it
didn't turn out at all the way the early
people thought were going to be the key
applications and things that you know
would not have been approved by uh you
know the the dark cabal making the
decisions about what gets into the store
turn out to some cases be extremely
successful uh so
yeah i definitely kind of wanted to be
there at the point where i did make a
pitch it's like hey make me vr dictator
and i'll go and get [ __ ] done i am and
that's just it's not in the culture at
meta you know and they they understand
the trade-offs they i and that's just
not the way that's not the company that
they want the team that they
that they want to do
you